nell'episodio precedente
la faccenda di buio in carica il gioco
l'ho detto io sono caduto io
no adesso c'era stato un paio dalla mia
vita e ho visto un maicon
io voglio questo è quindi amico mio cosa
che dovremmo fare in sostanza parte
vederti che stati la guarda brotto
fucile che spara caccole tu che aspetta
faccio il nero che fa paura come devono
andare alla fisa carcello arriva eccoti
è un fps esatto salire è vero che alla
fine ci troviamo a combattere null'altro
sander pure silvio ti ricordavi il nome
leo caro nicosia ma poi ho fatto saltare
qualcosa a cazzo ne so se sempre la
persona che ami ti tradisce c'era sempre
tu sei la voglia che devo lasciare il
patto è vero comunque vedi che io posso
fare esplodere la tua e robe guarda
vediamo st tedesco colpire per eccovi ma
che figura è una sorta di effetto a
catena
se si sente questo devo fare ma qua qua
e disintegrato sto coso potevo far fatti
ma se volete che si spacca ecco bravo
fai quello di legno è capito la fisica e
non è un'opinione trattato bene
è vero che siamo dentro dell'interno di
attolini però questa è proprio la loro
base per legare la band che dobbiamo
fare qualche tiro avversario scommetti
iniziato davvero bellissimo se vado a
perché io ho tre proiettili capito o
solo quei tre poi se non ci sono si
ritirano è una case le nostre altre 80 è
però quando si scarica tipo dietro il
sapone
ok perché dobbiamo fare così tu devi
appiccicare io devo sparare se non si
può accanire 47
ok quindi tu sei inutile senza di me io
senza di te bue esatto ok figo dai basta
ora vanno avanti e bello che ed è che
rendono sempre utili per l'altro esatto
esatto veramente pochissime che
e vabbè tanto si è pagato è rimasto una
melma attaccata a luglio
ok eccolo questo lo posso fare anche la
sola l'ho fatto anteprima quindi è stato
però sotto albero ti ricordi che un
albero questo come può essere così siamo
detti ancor più piccoli noi esatto non è
possibile quando bisogna fare bravo in
grado non c'era arrivato mai tedesca
docente disfa cile ai co star ma
perfetto adesso arriva a cook si rinizia
alpina le palle
marco gli altri ok yes
questa è la gabbia amico mino centri 2
primo anno negli eroi dove dell'atom ma
tu devi tutto praticamente appesantisce
le cose però devi beccare il duro
riguarda sì è vero che oggi sono oggi
c'è un esito positivo
oggi c'è un iq positivo è sfruttiamolo
perché non è che capitano
cosa facciamo questo queste cose di
fermare su minecraft esattori colpisci
di fila di non pensare to penso io oggi
io ti dico ok ok sali qua hai visto oggi
penso io per tutti firenze cosa che devi
tirare la culata futuro e vai vai vai
perfetto perfetto madonna è giocato
grande bene allora non solo insieme
vabbè c'è tutto sta roba l'anno costi
dei no aspetto fetta di fi ecco di farlo
no te la facevi sarà buttato nel vuoto
il fattore di più perché aspetta mai
adesso leggo
c'è un tombino ok è ora a mi sa che mi
fa aiutami aiutami nostra cosa a rosa
cosa dall'altra parte ciccio dall'altra
parte così via appesantisce poi oh oh
merda che aspetto aspetto
sono vivo per miracolo non sono anche
com che dall'altra parte di nuovo
bravissimo ma troppo tra
no di là ecco ho già fatto vaibhav
ancora ancora ancora ancora l'altra
parte all'altra parte
bravo ciccio bega india insieme siamo un
po ingegneri e noi dovremo aprire un
canale di ingegneria a studente per cui
ci che abbiamo ci amiamo
ieri pero ieri ingegner giochi facciamo
una specie di mix traduca nella lega ai
partiti parco giochi in change and i
giochi ingegneri non si farà qua
oppure in genere comunque figc deve
essere io sai come lo chiamerei o un
naso gigante kat
e allora facciamo che mi fido di te
vediamo se lo fila militano di me stesso
bene io me ne vado ciò che è successo
cos'è cosa estero start a io posso a tu
sei lì fermo ma tu puoi muoverti la
bellissima sei dentro al cosa del tipo
di bioshock è infatti che ti posso
elettrizza no posso schiacciare fidarsi
e mandato ci ha dato fuoco beh è la
nostra vicenza e questa mi paga pazzi
aiutano a chi possiamo far morire i
diversi modi e bellissimo tranquillo ti
ricordi che quella volta che mi ha
invitato a casa tua non è vero non è
vietata che è tipica di questo aiuto
sono mai stato che succede sta roba
non lo so adesso viene aspirato nel
bellissimo laga messa e satie costone è
veramente statica sta cosa manca una
torta wow
se mi aiutato la castagna è un trita
castagna amico mio no va bene il gioco
migliore del mondo terme ma cos'è cosa
devo fare stop con stop nesci psi a
vederti ma dimessa di casa col
bellissimo vabbè pieni meno male che non
puoi morire cesta magia che ci ogni
volta che moriamo ci riporta a terra
ah no ok ok dice e la catena nel senso
che devo lasciare il peso che che giri
che quindi tu come dicevo sopra adesso
produttivo sopra seguire le indicazioni
fila di me ok visto rock banchina e oggi
brodo non lo so che doveva passare a
voler essere occhio continua a colpire è
il coso anche che sono un casino
il coso sopra regionale sono al e sono a
posto ha posto però tipo dobbiamo fare
quello che non ti vedo arrivare veste
fila di definito ok ok adesso sta ancora
girando poi ancora vespa che mi sta
inglobando occhio bravo morta ok questo
via no maledizione di colpire quello
sotto quello sattolo sottoposto qua se
ne vanno in cina più ok ho corso presso
chi è quello chi cacchio eva vice
paradis ho colpito quello sopra volo
sopra quello sopra con la soprano sopra
aria sopra quello un altro un altro non
quello l'altra figlia gaia che male vai
vai vai sotto media che porca fatto
questo fa malissimo
mi chiamano schivare quel quadrato è
difficilissimo lo sperato
colpisci cosa o di sopra di sopra con i
sovrappeso subito quello di sopra con su
vai filate rai che amministra spa tanto
lo colpì titolo colpisco ho capito
dovrebbe sganciarsi lui taglia che male
ma non è mica vini ricarica che doveva
chiamato in posti dark souls o di
schivare uguale tra l'altro minchia
quanto io abbia accolto
la porta dovrebbe esserci aperta se come
si apre appena lo battiamo perché non
sta vigilando mai detto è morto è quasi
morto solo colpisce ancora una volta
rollo disintegro madonna è stato rapito
non è morto ancora di niente aspettava i
o sbaragli è morto se gli spari
bravo dove colpiscilo dietro qua
dovrebbe essere appena per lo schifo è
morto che moratti aspetta ed ai e non
riesco a colpirlo
ce l'abbiamo fatta ciccio mia è l'ultima
cosa si è aperto un disastro è stato
madonna per ragazzi c'è tanta roba era
ora che i complimenti saputo che
l'attentatore cioè di spaziosità e
giampiero ride soldati si sicurezza ha
rilevato due intrusi beh che si facciano
i sistemi all'avanguardia non c'è
abbiamo fatto un casino ma era solo una
dei tanto la testa ai pensò fosse un
posto incredibile ma da qua un libro che
sono il mio padre al palalido campobasso
avresti mai pensato di aggiungere questo
momento 90 ma tu sei molto il signor
aggiunto che era un pezzo web ha
raggiunto è esatto questo è uno di
questi
tuo padre in un libro da chi avrei
giocato gioco
vince il secondo me c'è mio padre con
libro è che se ne va avviare il paziente
di satira e della gallina è questo è
tutto un dire ma perfetto con un
personaggio che anche un parte
ok eccoci ma piuttosto lo abbiamo dovuto
battere o ecco come ho detto che però
non abbiamo dovuto battere niente no col
cazzo ma questi sono scagliati si è
fatto male
quindi ti fa male anche ad esempio
costruito rizzi avvicino ammessi a
occhio che dà niente
vai se con lei sono finiti questi euro
andare archeo che vai vai perfetto mai
per queste
sono anime recuperate no vedeva resto il
dark souls profilate questa era la sua
lampadari cos'è sta roba ok fatto kaki e
grosso quest'albero buona bottiglia
aveva vespa intrappolato intrappolate
oggi occhio sono incazzati che devi
colpire cosi filati perché sennò
continuano uscire veste fino adesso me
lo sento propri siti appari oltre che
deve essere anche perché sennò palermo
che l'altro anche l'altro ok bravissimo
maledizione chi cacchio è quello nuovo
questo è nuovo di aver incassato quindi
occhio mi ha beccato mi ha fatto mai
elevato me tramite una battuta pro pace
lo capisci lo colpisce come c'è uno dei
le altre este sono morte tutte ma noi ce
n'è una quasi 142 qua due restino apple
e lo fa l'ho fatto l'ho fatto
quello sì ma c'è una vespa normale che
ti gira intorno c'è dietro idea quella
schifo sempre lui vabbè ma d'ora che
squadra forti servetto ci sta facendo un
danno pazzesco bravo bravo per te
madonna fortis ai prof
si sia che sta caricando ok sarebbero di
nuovo madonna mai avrò perfetto ma e
prostata aspetta
vai è morto non è morta come noi ora è
morto ieri siamo stati dei grandi siamo
fortissimi boa sopra madonna raga porca
vacca pollicioni in super stabile una
stima ma altri cinque vogliamo di queste
cose siamo morti solo nelle cagate tipo
di salto perché non ci vedo veramente
devi colpire questo coso sopra di te
guarda questo tutto tutto nel cervello
la ma lo sapevo perché abbiamo elevata
al dettato per sbaglio le trappole da
camera proceda bene ok
cos'è sta roba
ma che cazzo
ok tipo nasser massicci ma non so
proprio ok rispetto ad un'auto mentre
stava con lei di quadri la farò le
quattro che abbia vico aricoli qua si
sviluppa ad altissima ti prego farvi
vedere stato
eccola no a lei attaccata questo grazie
siamo bellissimi da 466 particolarmente
fi guarda che è nato nella madonna sarà
che cazzo di naso questa è la copertina
del video è fermo a onde medusa ok siamo
sì che scrivo effettivamente io non ho
mai toccato negoziatore avuto che rimane
a membro bryson che ha fatto male
brucia non esageratamente dà fastidio ma
immagino cosa che non ci sarebbe mal in
sicilia non si e poi ecco perché perché
esistono seri valle crati che utilità ma
tanto lo sai ma tanto lo sai che le
meduse divono tipo non mi dicono quanto
ma tantissimo e vero forse addirittura
si ma vorrei fare divulgazione
scientifica sbagliata anche perché
perfino non lo sa il tuo ma toriko io
riguarda anche alberto alberto scusami
sia signora angela viscuso sedico cagate
ma credo che le meduse possono anche
essere mezza immortalino senso che
comportano dal per cento d'acqua bravo
90 perfetto è qual è l'elemento del
del sale l'elemento stato l'elemento del
sale non lo so milan a tavola periodica
o niente perché volevo fare volevo farci
sembrare più stupidi quello che siamo
effettivamente e ci sono riuscito ok
cos'è sta roba non ho mai visto ha
superato andata bene e che c'è o di
vedere susta roccia pro o perche credo
sono su starace ma sappia qualcosa anzi
sì ce ne sono altri si sa poi puoi
viaggiare da uno di sti cosi all'altro
che di prenderlo al volo che va da bravo
para sosti cosi che fisica c'è poiché il
maggior nieto nardò perché siamo sotto
attacco adesso siamo quasi albero che
albero è arrivare nella camera da letto
di nostra figlia c'è un paese a sud
nautica che caffè su prezzati è un pesce
gigante modo è un pesce gatto non lo sa
lo possiamo dirigerà non si dirige la
somma è diventato nel mosto gioco che
cazzo che siamo nell'acqua dell'albero
del bacino visibile mai visto dove siamo
è diventato non è più tanto fisico sto
gioco come back e due a due bambole che
prendono vita non è che sia dicono che
sentivi per ottenere altre cose reali e
realismo almeno le altre cose accadendo
continua su questo gioco e siamo stati
trovati atti dei ricchi devi muovere per
stare sopra quota che sono schiatti ok
possiamo buttarci risorse ma ora stiamo
cadendo nel centro della terra non
esiste più niente
non esiste più c'è la regata che sono
arrivati al nucleo non lo so in fondo a
questo tunnel c'è il primo iscritto nel
mio canale perché abbiamo sempre perché
tra la prima basta o ci sei arrivato
cosa cacchio che sta qua aspettato un
essenza cos'è devono dare spiegazione lo
so sia un essenza
sarà francipane francesi ma dove stiamo
ancora che cazzo ne so e da due ore che
siamo in un albero e figurative schiva
non sta nel mezzo
adesso bisogna devi stare in mezzo a
fare quello che vuoi ascoltare così da
me che sono un po quello non so dove
andare ok no vabbè un casinò in mezzo
fra gran bordello el'ascensore
dell'albero comunque faremo uscire
teoricamente passati all'oceano che sta
sotto casa non sapevamo come ripete a
l'ascensore dell'albero
ok bella perfetto one touch ma è
bravissimo star madonna a questa
un'arena l'arena delle battaglie quella
dove ci prendiamo tutti i cani delle
vespe nel deretano mio vero lo facciamo
con consapevolezza a morte dicono a noi
brocco c'è uno schifo in terra ma che
schifo
meno male che non è un ragno ah no
questo è uno di quei cui si chiama il
caso è così estera pescara pescara bari
non c'ero ma occorrono è cornuto
occhio che non so come colpi non subito
però lascialo caricare bros coperti
parco lemonia dormendo io vado veri e
dei e si incastra a mente capello che
colpì madonna gli elevato tanto la
propria ma è morto brom ha detto
bastardo madonna che brutto forte è la
trasmissione voice thrones
a parlare è un coleottero
non sappiamo neanche la base della linea
degli animali che schifo sì sì niente
avrei visto delle persone che conosco
tutti animali a memoria ma questo è un
bon bon bon saperlo un como morbo è un
po che con di mello che casa a vyborg un
borsello tea pazzesca mai e dietro il
nostro amico quell 8 ma dove prima più
esploso papa varisco contro l'este vai
in groppa loro c'è nel senso ore
possiamo sparare per le cose a lo puoi
far saltare più e io lo posso sparare
quindi immagino che tu ma ciò che
débacle dire qualcosa a un certo punto
non so cosa è qualcosa si può eh no
questi nodi
a questi si ok perfetto non abbiamo
beccato dura per l'età di porco demonio
come pat in faccia ok a quella mira
assistita che c'era anche nei giochi
quelli delle sale giochi che tu stai
fermo dei colpi e le golosissime sono un
coleottero detto anche se in cuoio sei
un borgo robot
io non so distinguere una lepre da una
al centro in particolare ecco buono
ricordare i contraccolpi
ok borbeaux bort vecchia generazione
borbon bornia chelsea for borgo katy
elemento terra eterna certo la donna che
mira a 360 l'albero stabilendosi qua
quando ma quando mai
ah ecco è vero se non è l'alveare quasi
ok però a sta volando incredibile
popolare e vabbè o mores commenti si è
sacrificato per la moria questi quattro
no veramente combattendo inevitabile
quando noi con uno schiaffo cda una
festa praticamente sì praticamente sì
noi lo stiamo trattando come se fosse un
aereo in mano
gliene frega niente borbon board eccolo
sono le catene dentro alveare labor è
morto è morto orto credo che questo sia
il boss finale pro c'è però spinale del
dl audio
tu sei pronto no non attaccatevi bene
siamo nella merda vespa reggina però
devi colpire anche lei lo sa gravissimo
perfetto poi abbiamo tolto ok è come un
boss di dark souls pensano così ebbene è
vero ma è preoccupato e mai colpisci
qualcosa madonna che c'è anche la
tornella di sola con nella quella io la
chiamo alla gonnella è un ago quello
però lo dovresti prendere che fa male
però solo per criscito ha così rientrato
il piscina ed è proprio il padre foto
del dietro farle esplodere
faccio io o l'ha colpita non si fa
niente però di colpi la sua sulle ips è
ok ok io ho fatto la cina quindi a posto
ovvio che se molliamo ci può iniziare
tutto e quindi vai sulla ex bar tocca ad
altri l'orco demonio che botta la rai lo
faccio
hai fatto dietro io perfetto anche di
sopra bravo bravo anche di sopra sotto e
sopra e sotto o cao che trova davvero ok
sino ai fatto le fatto dilatare ok
occhio a questi analisti ha colpito
molto che è quasi morto
meno male che sei morto nella
nell'imparare meno male occhio salta di
sata ii sono bombe bar bon bon bon bon
bordo ve66 ha detto siccome dopo la
combattimento torna per di farci capire
che non è morto
grande borghetto ma sì sì questo è il
board [ __ ] ciccio morto ma colpi da
me non è neanche una volta stato
bravissimo
meno male che ci compensiamo verrebbero
dei bravissimo così si fa ad essere però
bravo colpisci lei dietro mi sarà bari
non ha calzato rar
ma mi sa che di colpirla dietro pietro
arvedi che c'ha le cose come hai fatto
colpi là dietro la lega di davanti eroso
fatto che il giro ok
uscivamo sempre dire perché dice che l
odio adesso vi faccio fuori occhi mi sto
facendo il giro quindi resisti ok è
staccato un pezzo dietro è così morta
corona dai qualvolta già minchia che
boxe fight ragazzi pazienti giorni di
qui le madonne rai siamo cascati però
opposto dare tutto per lei
io penso che sia tutto a posto ce la
portiamo a casa starci qualcuno dentro
che era la vela per reggina una cosa
temeva appena vi è una bacheca ripeti
che e verdicchio scorse soprannominava
la bellezza la bellezza è un bomb il
bomber è quello che sembra un rombo è un
bon bon bon bordo verso la spunta ora
avrò bon bon bon adesso spunta e incorna
al nettare che distrugge certo provo
guarda guarda come ti aspetta allora
siamo attaccati noi dal bomb bam bam bar
allora noi dobbiamo sparare a cosa vai o
no penso che sia un filmato ok
minchia e questo tipo alla wanted niente
bella sotto retto io è il bombo e il
ciccio amico mio con naso grosso siamo
salvi si marcano solito si pero manca il
nostro amico bar board che è morto
peccato siamo usciti sì sì ce l'abbiamo
fatta definitivamente
ecco ma dai madonna ragazzi ma è un
attimo messaggera ben fatti ma poi
abbiamo nessuna mira
beh infatti nessuno sa becca che cazzo
che schio hanno fatto hanno trovato la
le armi nelle patatine è possibile un
porto
ma come ci ha abbandonati sì ma come
questa roba che è un album in cui con le
mutande e la bottiglia esatto va beh sì
se non c'e la mente beccati a un metro
dovete beccarci li codice guscio ma
adesso sono nostri amici e adesso sì che
dovremmo fuggire pro borbeaux bort guida
io devo sparare capito o in coma
divertiti come faccio ma come gioca
invertito nicchia pro sempre ubriaco
sempre come cazzo ti prego non si
schiantarono addio tanto bene detto ok
ok dove cacchio vai e scusa per ho visto
delle robe che non saprete scrive come
ha divertito molto bene ma io penso che
zoomare e by lago siamo usciti c'è sarei
soldato ryan orco demonio ci ha fatto
cadere qualcosa alla fine può picchiare
eh sì non lo so ma ora come finali metal
gear uno però gli eroici credo però solo
in the name verso stili quickening
tensione ma che cazzo ne siri occhio ai
ama il fortissimo però farci perdere non
c'è mare guida o bravo bella e brava
bella ma questo qua ma che cazzo e broli
aspetta che male
street fighter il confronto un cazzo ma
è proprio lo ha battuto per niente ok
ma si portino a un portiere perché i
ball ma allora ci diano reference ottimo
secondo me dovremmo andare verso casa
visto che ci stiamo schiantando poi
dobbiamo rifare tutto daccapo
dall'oceano e si rimettono in serbo
adesso no nelle fogne no proprio dai cup
a capriata il peso come il pezzo è vero
avrò cava anche perché devi andare a
cena
porca vacca che mira già brevissimi ok
eccola è una catena possiamo entrare
dalla finestra
incredibile ce l'abbiamo fatta
[Musica]